how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and we are getting
closer and
closer to the end of wanda vision there
are only three episodes left
but the big question still remains who
is the villain
of wanda vision we are made to believe
that it's wanda but that seems a little
too easy
and a little too obvious right now it's
clear that wanda has control over
westview but a lot isn't adding up
wanda says that she doesn't remember how
any of it happened
she doesn't remember how it started this
is a clear sign that she wasn't the one
that initiated it the spell over all of
the people the energy hex around west
view
it doesn't seem like she started this
she may control it now
partially but she didn't start it so if
wanda isn't responsible for
starting these things who did it well i
believe that there are hints given to us
in one division episodes one through six
that might tell us
exactly who it is and i'll explain every
single one of these hits from one
division
in this video if you love marvel and
want to stay up to date on one division
and all other marvel projects coming be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos
now the first thing that we have to
examine here is why is there a force
field slash energy field around
west view why is the energy hex there at
first thought we all thought
wanda was creating it to keep everybody
out she has her perfect reality here in
this hexagon energy shield
but remember what monica rambo said in
episode 4.
hayward said that wanda is controlling
thousands of people and then monica
rambo
said that it could have been thousands
more if she didn't have put
up her own quarantine so wanda did this
so she couldn't hurt other people
and do you remember what monica said to
wanda when wanda came outside of the hex
energy barrier
she said you brought me in you trusted
me
why did wanda bring her in to help you
don't bring somebody
into your perfect world to help if it is
a perfect world
if you have a perfect world you don't
need help but wanda needed help so
she brought monica in but what did she
need help with what was wanda trying to
contain in
with her energy force field and to top
it all off monica said that wanda
protected her when she blasted her
across new jersey and
out of the bubble wanda is protecting
monica and seems to be trying to contain
whatever the threat is wanda told vision
do you really think i'm controlling
everything that i am somehow in charge
of everybody in west view
and then she says i don't know how any
of this started in the first place
again another clear sign that she didn't
start it herself
so wanda is aware of what's happening
and yes she can control these people now
but she didn't started
also remember wanda's magic couldn't
control the stork
in episode 3 she tried to get rid of the
stork but she couldn't
and then she tried to use her magic on
the twins and it didn't work either
more signs that wanda isn't 100 in
control
now i know that i've pushed a lot for
mephisto to be the villain in one
division but i believe that the villain
is actually going to be
nightmare and i believe the nightmare
started it then gave wanda control but
not full control
and i believe that quicksilver could
even possibly be
nightmare in disguise but the question
is
what is nightmare's plan well he feeds
off of fear he specifically draws power
from
the psychic energies of people's minds
and in the comics it's when people are
dreaming
but of course we know that marvel tends
to change things in the marvel cinematic
universe but you could say that the
people in west view
are in somewhat of a dream state sword
used the term
awakened when referring to what vision
can do for these people he can
awaken them out of whatever state that
they are in when they are awakened they
can remember
everything their family who they are
they even realize that they are trapped
but when they're in the other state
nothing and this could be a so-called
dream state for nightmare in the marvel
cinematic universe
now wanda is controlling everybody in
this town and as we've learned
they're all in pain they're all scared
and worried
just take a look at norm in episode 5
when vision awakens him
norm is more than afraid he is terrified
and he said that he's in a lot of pain
and also in episode 5 we learned that
monica described being under wanda's hex
as terrifying
this is what nightmare's plan is to trap
all of these people and have wanda take
control
think about this one of the strongest
heroes alive if not the strongest one
a hero that people looked up to now has
people trapped and in pain
this creates even more fear somebody who
you thought was a hero and would protect
you
is the one responsible for your pain but
it's not wanda who actually trapped them
it's nightmare now i believe that
nightmare or whatever they're going to
call him or her because it could
actually be agnes which i'll get to in a
bit but i believe that this villain who
is feeding off of fear is going to be a
combination of both
nightmare and mephisto this wouldn't be
the first time that marvel did this
they did this with hella and thor
ragnarok they gave her powers of
gore the god butcher and this was
confirmed by them as well
and let's not forget that nightmare was
confirmed a long time ago to be the
villain of doctor strange 2
and unless they've completely changed
what they had planned he still should be
the villain in fact he was supposed to
be the villain for doctor strange number
one
but they decided to go with dor mamu and
leave nightmare for doctor strange too
so he should be the villain and we've
also had many references to
the devil in one division and not to
mention demon spawns in the last episode
quicksilver literally says unleash hell
demon spawn
and as most of you know in the comics
the twins are actually a part of
mephisto's soul they are
literally demon spawns that's too many
mephisto references for his character
not to be at least
somewhat involved but it's also a little
bit obvious now
this is why i think it won't truly be
mephisto but i think his story and some
characteristics will be added to
nightmare another big hint that leads me
to believe that nightmare will be the
villain is
we saw dead vision and dead beatro
i believe that these were actually
glimpses of nightmare's power
and his control over wanda because
remember nightmare would be using wanda
to put everybody
else in a fearful state so he could feed
off that fear
and if he's going to want wanda to
continue to control people and keep
their fear alive he's going to need to
do the same
to wanda and by showing her that vision
is in fact dead and her brother too he's
showing her that she can't
leave this reality if she wants them to
stay alive so the thought of everything
collapsing her perfect reality envision
finding out and sword breaking in
all of this scares wanda which is
exactly what nightmare would want
now i actually think that one of the
biggest hints towards nightmare being
the main villain is
that really weird commercial that we got
in episode 6
the yo magic commercial with the shark
now there are a lot of different
interpretations for this commercial in
fact when i did my breakdown about
episode 6 i said it meant something else
as well
but i believe that the shark is actually
nightmare he is
feeding off of her magic because her
magic is what's causing all of the fear
and it could be how nightmare himself is
surviving we don't know what nightmare
is going to be like in the mcu but we do
know that in the comics he comes from a
different realm
a different dimension so perhaps wanda
has created a realm a dimension a
reality
in which nightmare could stay that way
he could survive in the main
reality that the mcu exists in right now
but the hex energy barrier has to stay
up people have to remain in fear so he
could feed off that and stay in this
dimension
so he is surviving off of wanda's magic
which is why in the commercial he says
stay alive
with your magic now as i mentioned i
think nightmare could be
quicksilver in disguise think about it i
don't think anybody really thinks that
quicksilver is actually pietro
and not to mention funko just came out
with a quicksilver funko pop
but notice how they said his name it
says pietro
maximoff and quotes implying that it's
not
actually pietro maximoff but why is he
disguised as the x-men
version though well if you remember what
wanda said when talking to billy and
tommy about bringing people back from
the dead
wanda said that there are rules and you
just can't bring people back to life
yes she brought vision back from the
dead but he was a synthesiod not an
actual person
so nightmare probably couldn't use the
old pietros from age of ultron
body so what he could have done is
plucked the other pietro from the x-men
fox universe
out of that universe and brought him
into ours and he could be under the
control
of nightmare he could be possessing him
controlling him much like wanda is
controlling the people of westview and
he's playing it off
very well like he is wanda's brother he
has the same memories just a different
body
and also remember what he said to wanda
when she first saw him he asked if he
could squeeze her to death
more evidence comes from the halloween
episode when they're talking about the
reality quicksilver said she handled it
well he seems to be aware of
everything that is going on with wanda
he knew that there weren't any kids
before what he calls the halloween
special
and he said that he assumes that they
were all sleeping in their beds
he says she handled the ethical
considerations of the scenario the best
that she could
almost like he knows exactly what she
did because maybe
he's done it before or he started it out
for her
he goes on to say that he is very
impressed with how she handled
everything
almost like he's done it before and
knows what it takes and he also could be
very impressed because it's her first
time
doing this and maybe she even did some
things that he himself
couldn't do which is why he asks how she
even did
all of it now this could actually be
quicksilver trying to get intel
for nightmare because if he is under
nightmare's control
nightmare could have also given him
tasks to do maybe worked out a deal with
quicksilver to eventually let him go
because it's very clear that quicksilver
has a very specific job to do
and he actually states what his job is
i'm just trying to do my part
okay come to town unexpectedly create
tension with the brother-in-law's drop
trouble with the rugrats and ultimately
give you grief
so it's clear quicksilver has a very
specific purpose essentially creating
chaos and causing
wanda to grieve and possibly be fearful
of what is about to happen to her family
now nightmare could actually be agnes
who i still think is agatha the harkness
but they may actually combine agatha
harkness nightmare and mephisto
into one character that could be agnes
after all norm did say in episode 5
you have to stop her she's in my head he
didn't specifically say wanda and i
think that's on purpose i think it could
be
agnes or ag of the heartness nightmare
and mephisto combined into one character
that could be
agnes but nightmare's powers being the
main powers here
but at the same time nightmare could
just as easily be controlling agnes
after all it did seem like agnes was
under wanda's hex in the last episode
that we saw it is very clear that
someone very powerful
is influencing wanda and helped her in
the beginning since she didn't remember
starting all of it
and we know that this started when wanda
was experiencing
extreme sadness what better time for
nightmare to strike
and if we look at all the facts and
evidence it sure does look
like this villain could very well be
nightmare and a possible combination of
nightmare and mephisto but let me know
what you think about this
in the comments down below do you think
that the villain is nightmare or do you
think that it could be somebody else
be sure to let me know and don't forget
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest wanda vision or
marvel videos don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you